i'm dr liz farkerson i'm working here at
sardi at the plant research centre at
the moment i'm working on a grdc project
that's looking at improving the nitrogen
fixation of pulses and we're doing that
through
looking at the agronomy inoculation
practice and also development of new
rhozobia strains
we're looking at a whole range of crop
types in the project we've got a big
focus on the group ef pulses to start
with because they're growing extensively
in southern australia so that's the
fava beans lentils field pea and we're
also including vetch in that group
but we're also looking at chickpeas and
lupins
this year we have trial sites over at
port broughton also at heart and at
lochsten in south australia as well as
some trial sites at neil in victoria
with our collaborators over there at
fort boughton this year we have a
chickpea trial so chickpeas aren't grown
as widely through the southern region
their history isn't as long here and so
generally growers need to inoculate
chickpea crops particularly if they
don't have a history of the crop in
addition to that we find that
anecdotally that chickpea just doesn't
seem to nodulate
as well as
some of the other crops like lentils so
at the child this year at port broughton
and also at our site at neil we're just
looking at a range of treatments that
might improve chickpea nodulation
so here we have some
chickpea plants here and some lentil
plants over here both collected from our
port broughton site so
port borton had a history of both
crop species but
it's been growing lentils for many many
years whereas i think chickpea was only
grown for the first time three years ago
and so
chickpea only has
around 10 nodules per plant
at this site even
with inoculation we were able to improve
that slightly
but ultimately we'd like to see better
nodulation on chickpea than we're
currently seeing on these plants in
comparison lentils were very well
nodulated they have not been inoculated
at all and yet we're seeing 50 or more
nodules per plant which is considered
adequate nodulation
and those chickpea nodules as you can
see here
are nice and pink and we're also seeing
the nodules on both the tap root and out
onto the lateral roots
so what growers can consider when
they're growing chickpeas is consider
inoculating every time unless you have
an excellent history of chickpea in the
rotation and you know that those
chickpea crops in the past have been
well nodulated so an important thing
growers can do each season for all pulse
crops is around
10 to 12 weeks after sowing and into
early spring they can consider digging
up
some pulse plants out of their each crop
have a look at the nodulation and make
sure the crops are well or to adequately
nodulated that'll help growers make
informed decisions about whether
inoculation is needed into the future
and there's lots of resources on the
grdc website where they can
access more information on how to do
that and what prizes good modulation